un festejo patriótico a lo grande el
gobierno de nicaragua invitó a sus
ciudadanos a reunirse por todo el país
con motivo del bicentenario de la
independencia de españa y pese a un
repunte de jovi 19 la pandemia no nos ha
dejado tregua sin embargo eso no podemos
nosotros dejar de celebrar una fecha tan
histórica como ésta este colegio público
realiza una demostración musical para su
comunidad por solicitud del ministerio
de educación que organiza las fiestas
patrias donde la juventud es
protagonista hoy es mi primera vez
sinceramente de salir en la en la
financia y pues sí me sentí feliz y
alegre
pero 300 estudiantes porque lo que se
tiene que tomar en las medidas de
bioseguridad porque lo más importante es
lo que está orientando nuestro gobierno
a cuidarlo este país se atraviesa una
grave crisis social económica y política
en medio de una oleada de arrestos a
opositores de cara a unas elecciones en
las que daniel ortega busca un cuarto
periodo presidencial en costa rica donde
se han refugiado la mayoría de
opositores nicaragüenses el político
enrique sáenz señala que estos festejos
obedecen a una estrategia política
conocida como 'pan y circo' en la
antigüedad las dictaduras no tienen
imaginación y repiten lo que otros
dictadores han hecho en otros tiempos no
sólo en la época contemporánea sino que
esto de 'pan y circo' viene desde los
romanos
así es que lo que pretenden es aplicar
este tipo de
políticas para distraer la atención
sobre todo de la juventud en nicaragua
los festejos patrios fueron acompañados
por 10 días de vacaciones a los
trabajadores del estado y estudiantes
así como la exoneración de impuestos al
sector turismo